let's say I have some function f that is
continuous continuous on an interval
continuous on an interval between a and
B and nine of these brackets here so it
also includes a and B in the interval so
let me graph this just so we get a sense
of what I'm talking about so that's my
vertical axis this is my horizontal axis
I'm going to label my horizontal axis T
so that we can save X for later I can
still make this Y right over there and
let me graph this right over here is the
graph of y is equal to f of T now our
lower endpoint is a so that's a right
over there our upper boundary is B upper
boundary is B let make that clear and
actually just to show that we're
including that endpoint let me make them
bold lines filled in lines so lower
boundary a upper boundary B we're just
saying and I've drawn it this way that F
is continuous on that now let's define
some new function let's define some new
function that's the area under the curve
between a and some some point that's in
our interval let me pick this right over
here X so let's define some new function
to capture to capture the area under the
curve between a and X well how do we how
do we denote the area under the curve
between two endpoints well we just use
our definite integral that's our Riemann
integral it's really that right now
before we come up with the conclusion of
this video it really just represents the
area under the curve between two
endpoints so this right over here we can
say is the definite integral the
definite integral from A to B from a to
X I should say from a to X of F of T of
F of T DT D DT now this right over here
is going to be a function of X and let
me make it clear where X where X is in
the interval between a
be this thing right over here is going
to be another function of X this value
is going to depend on what X we actually
choose so let's define this as a
function of X so I'm going to say that
this is equal to upper case upper case f
of X so all fair and good upper case f
of X is a function if you give me an x
value that's between a and b it'll tell
you the area under lower case F of T
between a and X now the cool part the
fundamental theorem of calculus the
fundamental theorem of calculus tells us
let me write this down because this is a
big deal fundamental theorem theorem
that's not an abbreviation theorem of
calculus tells us that if we were to
take the derivative of our capital F so
the derivative let me make sure I have
enough space here so if I were to take
the derivative of capital F with respect
to X which is the same thing as taking
the derivative of this with respect to X
which is equal to the derivative of all
of this business let me copy this so
copy and then paste which is the same
thing I've defined capital F as this
stuff so if I'm taking the derivative of
the left hand side that's the same thing
as taking the derivative of the right
hand side
the fundamental theorem of calculus
tells us that this is going to be equal
to
it's going to be equal to F lowercase F
of X now why is this a big deal why does
it get such an important title as the
fundamental theorem the fundamental
theorem of calculus well it tells us
that for any continuous function f if I
define a function that is the area under
the curve between a and X right over
here that the derivative of that
function is going to be F so let me make
it clear every continuous function every
continuous F has an antiderivative has
an antiderivative anti derivative
derivative capital F of X that by itself
is a cool thing but the other really
cool thing or I guess these are somewhat
related remember coming into this all we
did we just viewed the definite integral
as symbolizing as the area under the
curve between two points that's where
that riemann definition of integration
comes from but now we see a connection
between that and derivatives when you're
taking the definite integral one way of
thinking especially if you're doing a
definite integral between a lower
boundary and an x one way to think about
is is you're essentially taking an
antiderivative so we now see a
connection connection and this was why
it is the fundamental theorem of
calculus it connects differential
calculus and integral calculus
connection between between derivatives
derivatives and it or maybe I should say
anti derivatives derivatives and
integration which before this video we
disputed integration as area under curve
now that we see it has a connection to
derivatives well how would you actually
use the fundamental theorem of calculus
so maybe in the context of a calculus
class and we'll do the intuition for why
this happens or why this is true and
maybe a proof in later videos but how
would you actually apply this right over
here well let's say someone told you so
let's say that someone told you that
they want to find the derivative let me
just in a new color just to show this is
an example let's say someone wanted to
find the derivative with respect to X of
the integral from I don't know I'll pick
some random number here so pi to X of
I'll put something crazy here cosine
squared of T over over the natural log
of t minus the square root of T DT so
they want you to take the derivative
with respect to X of this crazy thing
remember this thing if we this thing in
the parentheses is a function of X its
value it's going to have a value that is
dependent on X you give it a different X
it's going to have a different value so
what's the derivative of this with
respect to X well the fundamental
theorem of calculus tells us it can be
very simple we essentially we
essentially and you can even pattern
match up here and we'll get more
intuition of why this is true and view
videos but essentially everywhere where
you see this right over here is an F of
T everywhere you see a T replace it with
an accident becomes an F of X so this is
going to be equal to cosine squared of x
over the natural log of X minus the
square root of x you take the derivative
of the indefinite integral where the
upper boundary is X right over here it
just becomes whatever you were taking
the integral of that as a function
instead of T that is now a function of X
so it can really simplify sometimes
taking a derivative and sometimes you'll
see on exams these trick problems where
you have this really hairy thing that
you take a definite integral of and then
take the derivative you just have to
remember the fundamental theorem of
calculus the thing that ties it all
together connects derivatives and
integration that you can just simplify
it by realizing that this is just going
to be instead of a function f of
lowercase F of T it's going to be lower
case f of X let me make it clear in this
example right over here this right over
here was lower case F of T and now it
became lower case f of X this right over
here was our a and notice it doesn't
matter what the lower boundary of a
actually is you don't have anything on
the right hand side that is in some way
dependent on a anyway hope you enjoyed
that in the next few videos we'll think
about the intuition and do more examples
making use of the fundamental theorem of
calculus